you are taking a step back from phil  right now and don't know how long  that'll be i need to be in the place  that makes me happiest and i take my job  very seriously when i'm at work and it's  a 24 7. and um i just want to be 24 7  with my babies and my family that's it  and we don't know how long or how short  but it's that's where i'm going to be  for a while what's one of your favorite  sandra movies i mean like that there  literally are so many the one that like  i talked about a bit is while you were  sleeping because that was one that we  watch every christmas in our house but  like speed is also a phenomenal movie  still like it is so good and miss  congeniality she's had a very good  career